welcome to this video round nine
coverage of the same field gap yeah this
is the penultimate round and of course
we already have a winner with fabiano
caruana only question is and how will he
finish this tournament will he get into
even more wins or just draws I will even
lose a game but possible does not seem
like that in this tournament but it
could happen yeah let's start and I
apologize for being a bit late with this
video usually I release it earlier but I
had some problems yes what if my
neighbors started to to drill holes in
the wall it seems and like number of
them and there are still drilling but
it's a little bit less obnoxious now so
I feel I can actually record a video
without being without producing
something that would absolutely annoy
you with because of the background noise
and the second thing is it took quite a
while for me to get some grips to get
two groups with one of the games let's
start by Sheila graph to palo we get
this opening yeah its own um very decent
choice for black and in fact also would
i play against with black against an
idea 3g three the system yeah but she
obviously decided to play something less
sharp something more solid until he
allowed even like to play e5 this is not
happening that often and only top
players decide to play instead of
castles to play deform or c4 to
immediately challenged in the center or
prevent the five at least but white is
just playing some sort of pills defense
reversed or yeah if you want something
like a Kings Indian attack like it's not
playing c5 where you can just castle and
now white captures on d5 so we get an
open center position where why it does
not really have any advantage but well
this is true with many opening so it's
just the kind of let's play a game
position
rookie 197 yeah 1970s of necessary
because why does threatening night xe5
possibly so if black does nothing move
let's say let's see place our age six
then this kind of thing is of course
coming black must attend to that this is
why you just retreated with a night this
retreat also has a dual purpose it
prevents the tactic but also enables
this kind of thing putting a knight on
d4 being able to actually replace it
with a new night if what decides to
capture it's an already a pretty an
equal position we have phone so normal
moves yeah why does some getting his
rooks connected black is trying to go
for deform to be perfectly honest given
the choice I would already a rather play
black here but it's probably about equal
with black I'm sure what I need to do
put something on deform and see if white
can can stand this for long Adam it's
probably not really anything else than
an equal position and 94 as mentioned
like once a night then and here he is
able to get a new night to d4 as soon as
its trade this is one of those ideals of
97 f five yeah and this is a good piece
on deform white cannot easily play see
three lines something like this blunders
the exchange this is the problem of a
night that's posted up on the Central
Square like here it's simply strong if
you cannot really ignore it forum for a
long time and if you push it will see
three well then the d3 pawn will be weak
or be 3 will be weak so there are some
drawbacks to that as well yeah we see
that here mvi let's play Queen d1
covering this critical square and then
playing c3 to get rid of the night and
then you play the queen bee three I
think this is a good approach getting
the Queen onto an active square yeah in
this
now to paula play to the solid Queen d7
yeah d3 looks like hanging if black
takes however you see that the screen is
in a sorry state like it cannot take ya
Queen d7 is just normal connecting the
rooks rookie three others might prepare
the doubling here playing maybe against
the pawn on e5 yeah like it's taking
this night away from its central square
but it might have a good other square on
c4 take stakes and rookie 6 plug is also
making sure that his five porn is
protected yeah King do you want getting
out of the long diagonal potentially a
problem for wide yeah in this position
we can certainly state that black has a
little bit more space with his points
here on e5 and f5 and there's also
always a slight very forward that the
deep porn might might be a problem it's
not something substantial at the moment
but it it could be tricky the the second
thing that it's not so nice for why does
this is Bishop only 3 which as always
yeah threatened by being captured um or
there's always the idea that like might
capture them and you don't really do
much so here it's a it's a question what
black should do the pile of plenty for
which is the the most direct move and
it's pretty much according to his style
is a very straightforward player may be
here here he would have had better
chances to do something if he played
some some slower move like let's say a 5
or yeah maybe a five is a move like that
or just another move that basically
stays tries to sort of them asked quite
okay what are you doing next after you
for it seems that we will get lots of
trades and it pretty much evaporates the
very very little and symbolic thing that
like head look if we look at this we see
that here with the deep horn and the e
porn being traded um lots of pieces have
been traded the rooks have been traded
and it's difficult to see how black
should should do anything he took on a
three gives him a little bit better porn
structure but white is is very active
like not played Queenie seven yeah what
about the capture this is cam just going
and white picks up pawns as well yeah he
went to e7 covering the seventh-ranked
h4 and now Queen c5 was played if black
takes cm then h5 is a slight problem
what are you doing now black cannot
really take and why this is even
threatening to take on g6 with check and
plain ith for this is not a good idea
black instead went with Quincy five to
make sure that h5 is not that dangerous
it was played anyway and now we had this
this straight into an endgame here the
pile of took care and white got the pong
back here yeah we're very close to a
draw now in effect after a couple of
more moves here they agreed to a draw a
very M correct game yeah the draw here
why exactly yeah white um if you really
want the draw is white you can always
just take him and get to this position
which is simply completely dead yeah
white will always protect f2 and just
stays on the second-ranked with the rook
forever um the easiest way probably to
just just end the game but of course why
can't play any movie is not in any any
danger you can also retreat yeah I think
a pretty correct draw and one of the
more uneventful games of this event I
get both players some
on getting a bit a bit diet which is
understandable um yeah maybe to Paula
for this very little symbolic advantage
around here but nothing really that that
you could hope to to make many winds off
ok so the next game I'm going to look at
is Magnus Carlton against Nirvana
ronnian and let's open this and I must
admit right away that I'm not not sure
about the endgame yeah we will we will
see i invested a bit of time to get to
grips with it but i'm not one hundred
percent sure about some things let's
let's have a look we got a queen's
gambit declined and Magnus goes for
Bishop g5 the the traditional move on
Bishop f4 nowadays is some played a bit
more one reason is why Bishop h4s very
own prefer this is this this line the
Alaska defense of the Queens gambit
declined it's a super solid opening we
are black pretty quickly exchanges minor
pieces the bishops and the Knights one
good thing for blankets you get the
Queen to e7 where it has a good good
place that's not it's a place where the
Queen cannot be a be attacked by any any
pieces like if you put it on on the C
file for instance and the Queens gambit
dick that very often it will be opposed
to a rook on c1 things like that and
black generally welcome some trades
because he's got less space this is a
very very solid defense for black it's
difficult to win games with it but it's
also very difficult to crack um yeah we
see some fairly normal looking museum
takes takes it's an interesting set up
for for white that card is choosing not
a very common one but I think that if we
look at the position
here black of course managed to get in a
five so that his Bishop is enjoying some
more space Knight f6 before we should be
Sam this is a fairly typical type of
position um of the fourfold Alaska it's
always around equal and a nibble for
white my test a little something here it
is the d4 night which is nicely
supported by the III porn this knight on
d4 is just a strong piece and cannot be
channeled a challenge and white has
ideas to play on the queenside with b4
b5 may be at the right moment the bishop
can go to f3 and yeah black is just very
very solid and then tough too tough to
him to beat but black does not have any
big active possibilities it's the type
of opening that that you play if you
really just our came with a drawn and
want to be very solid maybe trying to
yeah sort of attempt opponent doing
something something um yeah less solid
yeah I think counsel played them played
a very nice plenty with Quincy five this
was very interesting if he wouldn't have
done that and played them let's say you
play nothing move here now like like Age
3 then 94 is quite quite nice for black
to get in you have those sacrificial
ideas and the night is simply a good
piece only form yeah something like this
can be answered by here and maybe even
nighty six can be an idea to challenge
this nice night on deform Katherine went
Queen c5 yeah basically forcing the
Queen trade and after g6 and a form
Aronian decided to take yeah you can
argue maybe he shouldn't have taken but
it's very difficult to avoid in the long
run White has this a5 a6 idea and after
why playing a five
you have a hard time you don't want to
play a 6 yourself as black freezing all
your pawns on light squares yeah he
traded and now we see that this is the
next thing that white can try play on
them on the B file Aronian played a 5
this is a very very tough move to play
as you pretty much say okay the B porn
will be here backwards forever and the
problem on the other hand it also has
some points it black plays nothing moves
like this white will play a five and in
the upcoming position after you could be
one and the possible doubling this point
on b7 will be yeah it totally fixed on
this under on the B file and also be a
problem it's very difficult for black
here white also might have the idea to
play a six break up the structure and
expose c6 as a weakness so a five is a
somewhat unconventional looking move but
it's probably a probably a decent idea
93 immediately looking at the a5 pawn to
b5 yeah note that something like this
it's not not giving black any big relief
there's also this additional idea yeah
Ruby 554 they're all pretty pretty
standard pretty standard moose now g5
was played by Aronian he was looking for
a way to make White's expansion with f4
harder to play that's why he went went
with g5 age three and here we come to to
a key position um yeah aronia now played
them a very sharp very sharp move that
it's the kind of move that either Lentz
you in trouble and then people criticize
you for it or it's it's solving your
problems
one of those two things he went with
beehive surprising move really trying to
sort of free in the position in one go
the idea said after the capture which is
mandatory rupee a dulce was played and
black simply wants to get the porn back
and this way trying to trade his be porn
against the sea porn yeah getting rid of
a weakness on b7 however this whole
thing has some some some drawbacks
mostly um exposed by Carlton's next move
which is very strong we played f4 yeah
attacking the rook on e5 and more or
less forcing what's what's coming next
black took on III need to get need to
get the spawn and now night c5 was
played very nice move you get to the
good square on c5 and set up lots of
technical ideas black now um took on b6
if he doesn't do that he will have huge
problems with the B porn for example if
black girl plays the capture here there
is rook takes f form being an even
bigger problem just just tactically this
is a big issue if black now takes yeah
we have root k f6 yeah all based on this
this tactic so it says something else
yeah this may be we have be seven and
you're in a bloody pinion not good the a
black must take the pawn there is no
choice I just want to show that this
arises basically by force after after b5
king f2 yeah attacking in this rook all
this is sam is strong plane and forces
flag to be super accurate g takes f
needs to be played if you if you do
something like this why place gp1 check
keen the aid and groups d 7 is gone
he must take ya now rook takes a form we
have a comparable position to that to
one that I showed before with white
having now multiple threats Luke f6 is
the biggest one takes 97 winning in the
house yeah black must defend with the
smooth a very good defense he took on f6
now and aronia now played Bishop 38 we
had a weird looking move yeah it's clear
that okay this is not working right wins
big material but black also had to look
checks and I think that this probably
was the better defense it looks like a
very shaky move in a way but check it
also sets up this pin the difficult
thing is that this type of position is
probably okay for black but it's very
hard to see that beforehand because it
looks really strange that your king is
in the middle of the board and white has
all the active looks but the the
computer didn't find a win here for what
maybe this was black Sam best defense
after Bishop v8 I think he's in more
trouble rook f4 cakes must get the piece
back and now before this is the reason
why probably the other choice was better
this now is totally forced check and
white emerges with them better route
endgame um of course why turn as an
advantage it's got the more active rook
and you will get one of those pawns
black will definitely does not want to
play a move like that I mean this is not
even considered by a strong player y
term advances the king and marches the
porn so this is this is nonsense black a
must-play actively um to be honest the
the next couple of moves really am not
totally clear to me some things are
clear to me later in this end
game and maybe I should should show you
those and then try to puzzle puzzle the
way back I can show you what happened
now Aronian played a rook to before the
activating is rook rook takes c5 yeah
something like this is of course just
the draw yeah two against one is useless
white must keep a sum his a pawn rook d4
ok 6 Kim G 7 a-5 all this looks looks
fairly normal g4 so it's it's clear that
black is Sam is fighting for his life
here but the next move and what comes
afterwards is not not clear to me at all
aronia had a clear idea how to organize
his defense the question is is he able
to reach this what is what is getting at
in the game he was and this in a way
justified the the next move but there
was one particular position where Carson
could have won the game but I'm not
clear it's not clear to me if around
here black has a much better defensive
tribe than what the wrong Yin played for
example if if black plays this like here
I think that why probably should win
this if you get to see 5 here take but
the the king you can probably go all the
way here but I really didn't have the
time to look at and all of that so let's
let's check the game because it was very
interesting aronian played h5 which
looks crazy because you just give up the
pawn but it has a very very clear idea
cards and captured check check and the
sea point is running this is the super
critical position of
this end game the amazing thing is that
exactly here Carlton had a win but he
didn't play it he didn't play it um he
went with age six which looks perfectly
normal at first but it turns out that
this gives away this game toward wrong
I'll show you later because it's not
totally apparent to you unless you
really know those endgames exceptionally
well white here could have won with King
c2 which does not look very intuitive
but it does prevent the setup that
happens in the game and you will see
this later black kia has a problem
because he does not get the rook on the
fifth-ranked to get the the sideways a
tech going maybe it's easier if I show
you how the game ended in a draw age six
was played and now aronian played rook
to be three he wants to get here and
then ultimately to f5 this happened in
the game and you might not believe me at
first but this is a draw it's this is a
defensive method known as The Vancouver
defense what black is doing here or the
defending side is doing here text
White's a porn from the side and the
problem is white really cannot make any
progress here as long as the a porn is
attacked the white rook needs to cover
it if you lose the a porn it's it's
clearly a draw because we are in front
of the age pawns and this means that
white can only really get anywhere if he
gets the king near the near the pawn and
then black starts to give checks check
something like this check check check
and so on check check check check
yeah you can Jack give all those checks
but you always need to return back to f5
to get this 5th ranked defense going
it's a it's really just a draw and this
this happened in the game basically
mangla sir try to try to try it on but
there really wasn't anything happening
like was just happy to have his rook on
the fifth rank and always attack the a
porn check him check check check there
was just one shot in the moment where
there was jazz a trick quite sure where
was it I move ATM check where they
continued it for a very long while check
yeah it's the same thing on the
sixth-ranked this is the original
vancouver position with the rook on f6
but it's just the same thing note that
if you give this tour to a computer
without any table base it will give
white plus 5 4 plus 4 or whatever this
is this nonsense this is really just the
raw the compt is not it's not able to
calculate this that this is just a
chance of mechanism that's so breakable
in jamia there was only one point with
age 5 check yeah here of course black
just needs to play king age 6 yeah not
take the pawn as this chapter Luke age 7
King anywhere a 7 is fatal and wide
we'll wide world wide will win get get
the king and promote but just here it's
we have a perfect defensive set up and
the couple moves later we had blank
Kings let's now return to the one
critical position that we had which was
around here so exactly after this moose
white could have played kings CT yeah
what is the big point of this the point
is that here black does not manage
to get to this sideways attacking
position of the porn like on f5 yeah why
not it's simply a matter of 10 PF black
gives us check here's an example why it
takes and now if you move over to the F
file something like here then where
white has rook be six or look d 6 or
whatever and then you can cover the porn
sideways and actually enter with the
King to win very easy even so this is
not working so what else is there black
can try to mark time with with King g7
for example and then white can can do
those things here and now we have a
problem what should like do now if you
go for instance to 2g eight after Luke a
7 a-6 and possibly group g7 later you
will get zoosk mind so that's a big
problem here what else is there
something else let's check you to look
at my notes what moves did I look at I
can try this yeah and it's again a
matter of time here again why this quick
enough to to get this in yeah it's a
little bit of a weird situation and so
it's it's a zoosk one kind of a quite a
phenomenon in the game really now Black
is threatening this and white has has no
way to to make any any headway if you go
through b6 for example then what was the
defense here Luke a 3m need to play this
hidden brook a 3 a 6
and how do I draw here yeah here black
can just go King h8 and again it's wrong
yeah don't that yeah if you if you look
at this with your computer and it says
plus form it should direct at you this
is really just the draw how is wide ever
going to to make progress here yeah this
rook is always covering the pond why
does not able to to get his King
somewhere to attack the rook let's say
this is not possible due to c 2 and
white has no way forward here absolutely
no way yeah the king is here is blocking
both h pawns you cannot move the upon
yourself this is a draw if you want to
want to check this whether the table
base for example the 6 p's table base
you can enter this position with without
the h 3 pond which is totally irrelevant
for the whole thing this is this is free
just to troll and yeah what else let's
let's check other possibilities white
rice trance this for example then what
is blacks best you can go to the 5th
ranked again or if you want after after
86 my notes are a mess here really or it
doesn't really make any difference this
is basically the same thing as in the
game just a wire different route what
it's not clear to me really in this end
game and I couldn't really find the time
to to get nearer the truth and if so
what is blacks best here then probably
h5 is not sufficient but I'm not totally
sure what you should do can you hold
with other moves maybe it also wants the
best practical chance to get to this
position and and let cars of find King
see to what you didn't do yeah I'm not
not 100
% sure about the end game but it seems
that I am NOT alone with this I also
checked some some online published notes
by grandmaster Sacco B&N to Ramirez and
those notes were also not quite quite
conclusive ok so let's look at the final
game here the third game of this session
kara piranha Nakamura so the tournament
leader against Nakamura was so yeah
certainly it was last in the tournament
and probably prefers to to forget about
the whole thing but still there are
games to be played and let's see what
what happened we gotta build in defense
not exactly what you expected but maybe
not come where I didn't really feel like
playing any any complicated game in this
is so you know whatever yeah kawana is
going for the end game which she
normally does and which I feel also
should be what white generally should be
doing I mean I don't think that the
other lines give wider want anything
can't while the end game is nothing
nothing brilliant and very tough to play
it's probably so what why should try
yeah I am NOT going to pretend that I
know much about the specific lines all
this has been played them quite often
and when we go all the way to here we
even find game references in this
position kingi too yeah as you see with
the time spent kawana only spent a
couple of minutes and nakamura even less
they both and you enter and aimed for
this position this has been played a
number of times and it's a fairly
typical endgame for for this line where
it's always the question if white can
maintain a little something or if it's
just very very dry my term
of course enjoys this three against two
so he has some some ideas with them yeah
gaining space on the kingside may be
using this majority however black black
is very very very solid and tough to
break down it's a yeah do we are just
not a particularly attractive position
for black because you never ever going
to winning game but it is very tough to
break down and maybe really nakamura
wanted to have something yeah which is a
bit easier to handle it's probably not
very thrilling to play but at least you
know what you're aiming for rook the
eighth this is new it seems Bishop takes
you three have been played before even
in games by kawana so on it's it's
something that both players know yeah we
got those trades in hoopty one Bishop d3
this is logical you want to get your f
porn involved takes and black played
route g6 in fact for for some moves I
think there is not much going on it's
really about equal root deform f5 yeah
trying to clarify the situation you on
the kingside bishop h4 yeah intermediate
attack on the night c5 checking in the
rook and no 95 all this looks logical
and I think should be should be ok 44
black take stairs and Bishop g3 keen to
d8 yeah and here we have an absolutely
critical position the night is attacked
and it must move so where do you go now
yeah in general it seems that black
shouldn't have any huge difficulties in
in reaching a draw as king as near the
the corn so it can help in the defense
and the pawn is not that that
at the moment still you need to answer
this question how do you want to go with
the night now camera now very
uncharacteristically retreated to e7 and
it seems that this is a mistake um yeah
I think he's really rattled by the
tournament the cause of events in this
tournament it turns out that Knight c3
getting a quicker counter play against
the pawn CM was the right way to go
after that there shouldn't be any any
big dangers for black it's still a
fairly complicated endgame this is not
this is not totally trivial position to
play but um here he definitely has come
to play something like him look fa to be
8 and like it's always threatening to
pick up their pawn and also in the if
you just compare to the game 97 check
will give a check and their form we see
that now white is getting the first
threats nf5 is something that needs to
be a taken care of black is in trouble
now he now went king to e6 and this is
probably the next inaccurate move at
first it seems that this could be a
defense trying to block and play Knight
to f5 but Bishop h4 is very strong you
threatening rook f7 or just to capture
with a very good rook endgame and the
big point is that night at five is not
good due to King g5 a very funny move
the point being that rook takes a look
takes f5 takes takes takes takes is a
win for white this looks at first you
think okay it should be when either the
protected pants are only five but then
you might recognize a weight like answer
is having stuff like that yeah what what
about this isn't he coming with b5
yeah white has a funny answer he needs
to play a five what other moves us but
this is winning here after this black is
not enjoying the response very much and
ultimately need to give up control over
f6 to let the pawn promote quite a quite
a funny line so this wasn't a viable
defense maybe look g6 check and then
just yet try to hang on here what's best
but black is already critical can you
think so ever it is really definitely
losing after that there is no one no one
escape anymore Bishop h4 now intending
rupee aid now this was forced there's
not much else and now white as its two
pawns it's not two points up I was about
to say that that's wrong it's just one
porn but they had two passes and as
mentioned it's it is lost now rook a 6cm
through cage seven king evade back yeah
now Luke h6 was played they also was
Bishop f2 which was very strong but this
move is also and sufficient to win 96
King to f5 King g7 yeah and here we come
to a key position of this game we are on
new 14 and kawana didn't have that much
time left we see that he's showing it
with 52 seconds left on the clock which
might might not be entirely correct but
he definitely didn't have so much time
if you like you can treat this as a
little exercise white white to play and
win I'm going to show you the move now
he didn't play it he didn't play it so
mr. perfect is making a mistake yeah I
work takes you six is the win here rook
chicks
and ii six yeah and this this is deadly
for like he has no defensive against
those pawns and simply e7 threatened and
what should black doom if he plays move
like that for example you go e7 and
there's no way to stop this check yeah
it's one way to break through yeah black
and black and try this but white is just
overwhelming and this will promote so
Luke takes 26 was the win yet not a very
difficult move but with 50 seconds on
the clock it's it it can be can be
tricky especially you are in a position
where more than one move wins it's not
like other moves don't keep your edge
but this is the the moment where you
could could wrap it up he went with two
F to check and after ninety seven key
for Brooke a fall black definitely has
gained something yeah I got some some
counter play it's still not really great
but you're not you're not dead you're
not dead anymore um here probably king
d3 was the toughest move but kawana went
with Ruby six yeah this was still able
but this white was still able to to
exert some pressure on black it's
however not a complete win anymore yeah
something like like this still puts up a
defense yeah he went with rookie six
knight c6 and King f5 him intending to
invade with the king who takes check now
check those checks were given I actually
expected now look g6 with the jaw simply
repeating but Kara wanna tried to fight
with g6 which is really this is
something that you
must give him credit for that he tries
to still win after he he spoiled it
earlier and pretty sure they had he had
recognized by now that he could have
wrapped up the game much easier earlier
and very often it is in fact a good idea
after you recognize you made a big
mistake let's bought your winning it rod
this is very often a good idea to just
just just end the game and forcing a
draw because very often you're even
blundered away this is very often coming
in mistakes are coming in pair safely
but when he tried on but it's not a
winner anymore and nakamura defended
chat accurately here now get to the rook
endgame but black is active enough he
has the deep pond and hallways those
checks from the back yeah it's all but
black also cannot win yeah why does far
to act of him check check so we had a
tunnel check check check and here they
agreed a draw so karana only whom he
drew this game after his fantastic run
but he could've yeah relatively easily
have won it if you would have found rook
takes g6 or um yeah maybe Anton move
from 38 there also was this moment where
Bishop f2 was was pretty strong but okay
he's not a machine he's also making
mistakes it's still an absolutely mega
performance yeah well nakamura at least
I've got a draw in this game and we are
settled for the final round being played
on saturday the sixth and yeah looking
forward to 22 coverage of this final
round let's see what what happens they
are coming can I already should turn
this off okay well thanks for watching
and I'll be back with final-round
coverage as well bye